こんにちわ！はじめしゃちょーです！
僕今ですね、静岡に住んでるんですけども
まあ借家なんですよね
借りてる
そう、今家を借りてるんですよね
なんやかんや言って人から借りてる家なんですよ
で、大家さんがすごいありがたい人で
こうなんでも出来るんですけども
結局
うわああああ～～っと
結局家を借りてる身なんで
毎月大家さんにお金を払って
家を借りてるんですけども
静岡を歩いてると
なんか
僕の目が正しかったらよ？
正しかったら～
ほんと！まじまじまじまじ！！
信じてないでしょう？
目が正しければだけど。。。
ほんと！ほんと！売ってたの！
なんか
普通に町の道路に看板がたってて～
一軒家２０万円みたいな！
今しかないよ！みたいな
今だお～みたいな
いやこれはもう見に行くしかないなというわけで
ちょっと今から
まぁ、わんちゃんアリですよね？
だって、え？
一軒家ってことはもう２０万払ったら
それでもう自分のものでしょう？
すぅ～
ということで今回はちょっとその看板の所まで行って
本当に２０万...
てかそもそもあってるかどうかも分からないんだよ
一回その本当にお家が２０万円で売ってるのか
どうかを今から確かめに行こうと思います。
でわっ！
でも２０万で借りてどうする？
でもなんでもできるんだよ？
家ってさ何が高いってさ
その建物自体高いじゃん？それに土地代ってのがあるじゃん
土地代払わなきゃいけないの？
はっはっはっは～
あぁそうか、土地代が発生するのかぁ。。
けどやっぱ大家さんとかさぁ
周りの人を気にせずさぁ
自己責任でしょう？
いいやん！
花火あげようや家で
家の中砂場にしてみたくない？
なんでもできるっていいよね
友人（犬とか飼いたいよね）
あそこらへんあそこらへん
本当に多分あったよ
え！？と思ったもん
友人（家賃とかじゃなくて？）
家賃ではなくない？だって
一軒家って書いてあったよ
さぁさぁさぁもうもうもうもうくるよもうくるよ
はいっ！
というわけで近くまできたので
ここからはちょっと歩いて看板を見に行きましょう。
わかるもんなの？
もう静岡でビデオカメラやってたらオイラなの？
見て、足元見てぇ
はっはっはっはっはー
ダサさの極みでしょうｗ
さぁもうすぐっす多分
信じてないでしょう？？
友人（全然信じてない）
黄色い看板であったんだよ？
え、まってそろそろだよ本当に
可愛い人多くね？
ほら！ほら！ほら！ほら！ほら！ねえ！ほら！ねえ！
ほらほらほらほら！！！
ほら！ねえ！ほら！
ちょっと待ってぇえｗｗ
はっはっはっは、、、
オーダーカーテンかぁ...ｗ
え、ずるいよこれは～
だってぱっとみさぁ、どう見てもさぁ
パッと見、どう見ても...
お家一件丸々２０万円でしょうこれは
ええ、でもさぁ思ったっしょ？
友人（思った最初ｗええ本当だって思った）
ええ～これはずるいよ～
完全にお家一件丸々２０万円かと思ったよ
ここだけ見たら完全にお家一件丸々２０万円でしょう
やられたね
え、でも本当にパッと見たらさぁ
完全に思うでしょう？
いや２０（の文字が）でかすぎでしょうｗｗ
まあ、世の中そんな甘くないですね
もし仮にそんな２０万の家があったら
多分買うと思うので
我々今ちょっと物件調査してるかね
安い一軒家とかがあると
ひょっとしたら買うかもしれないので
そういう時は皆さん遊びに来てくれよな？
んじゃ！！！